à l'opposé de la description qui a été
fait par les collaborateurs de la
présidence de la république est à
l'opposé des déclarations faites devant
la commission qui sont entre guillemets
dans le rapport et dans l' annexe à la
lettre que vous avez dans vos dossiers
déclaration faite par monsieur strzoda
par monsieur lavergne et par monsieur de
colère il sait il est apparu que
monsieur alexandre benalla avait exercé
devait une fonction tout à fait
essentiel pour l'organisation et la
gestion de la sécurité du président de
la république
au risque d'en perturber le
fonctionnement normal on a pu obtenir
non sans mal et avec retard cher
président la fiche de poste
la lettre de mission officielle qui
définissait les missions de monsieur
alexandre benalla et lorsqu on la lit et
elle figure en annexe du rapport on
constate que contrairement à ce qui a
été dit sous serment devant la
commission une mission spécifique de
coordination des services de sécurité de
la présidence de la république lui
étaient confiés et qu'il exerçait seul
directement sous l'autorité du directeur
de cabinet plusieurs éléments tendent à
confirmer que contrairement aux
affirmations des proches du chef de
l'état cette mission ne recouvrait pas
uniquement et loin s'en faut
des considérations à caractère
logistique à la lumière des témoignages
recueillis il apparaît qu alexandre
benalla fort de la confiance et de la
liberté d'actions qui lui étaient
accordées et dans l'ambivalence des
missions officielles qui lui étaient
confiées s'était arrogé un rôle central
dans le fonctionnement des services de
sécurité de ce qui est comme l'a rappelé
notre président la cinquième puissance
du monde
il est en particulier établi qu'il se
serait à plusieurs reprises immiscé dans
certaines décisions relevant la gestion
de la gestion du dispositif de la
sécurité du président de la république
ainsi en at il été de la mise en oeuvre
d'une cellule de réservistes de la
gendarmerie nationale au sein du
commandement militaire du palais de
l'elysée ou du recrutement de plusieurs
agents parmi lesquels monsieur vincent
kraz il est également hautement probable
qu alexandre benalla à dans les fait
participer activement aux dispositifs de
sécurité des déplacements du chef de
l'état prenant un ascendant sur les
responsables opérationnels de la
sécurité s'imposant comme un
interlocuteur privilégié des autorités
de sécurité publique la commission
également réuni des éléments concordants
donnant à penser qu alexandre benalla
exercer dans les faits une mission et
une fonction de protection rapprochée du
président de la république ce qui a été
pourtant obstinément nier par les
principaux responsables de l'elysée que
nous avons reçues en atteste tout
d'abord son positionnement permanent à
proximité immédiate du chef de l'état
lors de déplacements auxquels ils
participaient qui de l'avis d'experts
correspondrait à une position des pôles
jeu citant dream est chargé d'évacuer le
président de la république dans des
sites ercis dans des situations extrêmes
justifiée par le besoin de passer des
messages au chef de l'état un tel
positionnement paraît pourtant n'avoir
jamais été adopté par aucun des
prédécesseurs ni aucun des collègues
d'alexandre benalla surtout le permis de
port d'armes et j'insiste là-dessus qui
lui a été attribué en octobre 2017 par
la préfecture de police dans des
conditions inédites et dérogatoire au
droit commun
à tel point que l'intéressé lui même
avait envisagé à défaut un décret secret
du président de la république pour
l'autoriser à porter une arme et nous en
fournit sont la preuve
cela ne pouvait se justifier par
d'autres raisons qu'une fonction de
protection rapprochée le soutien appuyé
de sa hiérarchie à la demande qu'il
avait formulées de même que les
contradictions devant la commission des
collaborateurs du président de la
république pour justifier ce permis de
port d'armes accréditent l'idée
qu'alexandre benalla exercé des missions
de protection rapprochée requérant
contrairement à ses collègues le port
d'une arme
il a par ailleurs reconnu avoir porté
cette arme en présence du président de
la république ce qui est sans précédent
par rapport à un certain nombre de
situations identiques par le passé
qu'elle résulte d'une volonté expresse
la hiérarchie ou d'une vision extensive
par l'intéressé des missions qu'ils y
étaient confiées il ne fait nul doute
que l'intérêt que la présence et
l'interférence d'un individu
relativement peu expérimentés et
soucieux d'affirmer son autorité dans un
milieu de professionnels aguerris
sélectionnés et formés et plus constitué
une source de dysfonctionnements et un
facteur de fragilisation du dispositif
de sécurité du président de la
république la liberté les pouvoirs
excessifs laisser à un chargé de mission
dans un domaine aussi sensible que la
sécurité du chef de l'état témoigne aux
yeux de notre commission de l'imprudence
de la présidence de la république dans
l'encadrement d'un individu qui avait
pourtant fait preuve par le passé de
comportement professionnel inapproprié
vous lirez le rapport
la commission a ainsi découvert qu
alexandre benalla avait été licencié de
son poste de chauffeur personnel de
monsieur arnaud montebourg à leurs
ministres du redressement productif en
raison de son manque de jeu site
discrétion responsabilité et
transparence notamment parce qu'il
s'était prévalu du soutien du ministre
pour une demande déjà de permis de port
d'armes j'ajoute pour finir qu'il est
apparu que monsieur benalla a participé
une cellule très restreinte associant le
chef du gspr le commandant militaire et
que cette cellule était chargé de
définir une nouvelle stratégie pour la
sécurité de la présidence de la
république et du président de la
république et que l'objectif était pour
monsieur benalla comme il l'a déclaré
publiquement et entre guillemets c'était
dans le journal du dimanche d'établir un
système qui prendrait des distances à
l'égard du ministère de l'intérieur
perçue par lui comme faisant obstacle à
cette perspective qui était sans doute
d'autonomiser quelque peu le dispositif
de sécurité du président de la
république
contrairement à la tradition qui existe
depuis le début de la vème république
pour le dispositif de sécurité du
président de la république est
exclusivement constituée de policiers et
de gendarmes relevant hier du ministère
de la défense du ministère de
l'intérieur aujourd'hui pour l'essentiel
du ministère de l'intérieur